[Music]
this place
shaped the young prince
gordenstein was established in 1934
thousands of pupils have passed through
this independent boring school on the
murray coast
one of the first was prince philip aged
13.
his time here is remembered in books and
photographs
the school library contains the
recollections of school founder
and headmaster kurt hein
when he was in the middle school he got
into a fair number of scrapes through
recklessness and wildness
he was often naughty never nasty he had
the grace of leadership
he set high standards which became the
fashion
he never lost the childlike quality of
becoming absorbed by whatever he tackled
[Applause]
prince philip excelled at gordenstein he
was head boy or
guardian a natural sportsman he
captained the cricket and hockey teams
at his old school they do today as he
did then
pursuing a curriculum that extends far
beyond the classroom
in his day prince phillips sailed across
the north sea to norway
he also served with a schoolmates in the
local coast guard patrolling the murray
coast
school days taught him the value of
leadership and community engagement
what grew at gordenstein was a
commitment to succeed
for himself and for others and it built
a platform for the charity
that would bear his name the duke of
edinburgh's award
the murray badge which was then on offer
to the local community was a way in
which other students not just those at
gordon
could benefit from that kind of
challenge and community service
and with the supports of kurt hahn the
murray badge then became the duke of
edinburgh's award and so has benefited
young people all around the world
young people have felt its benefits in
more than 140 countries
over more than 60 years the duke of
edinburgh's awards scheme encourages the
values that he held dear
service skills physical recreation
and adventure it's given me like a lot
of um
lessons about life in general to be
honest
and how to treat different people i feel
like this
it accentuates character it really
brings out
who you really are like your true soul
your true being just because
we're working together we're learning
things
back through the duke's life there's
always been an extremely strong
commitment to
to young people in all the charitable
activity that he's done
a huge commitment i think to young
people getting into the outdoors and
experiencing
the environment and and developing
resilience in that environment and just
just the joy of it actually you know not
trying to turn young people in nestle
interval
mountaineers but to get them engaged in
the local habitat and learning more
about the world around them what do you
want to see me about
as his public profile grew so did prince
phillips charity work
this video shows a 1951 appearance as
president of
fields and trust
the bodies set up to protect playing
fields and green spaces i
wish we could just go out and buy a
field and it's not as easy as that
he was very instrumental in the work of
the organization
and in raising its profile and really in
understanding how important it was to
try and generate income to support the
charity
across his career the duke of edinburgh
was patron president
or supportive in some way of nearly 800
organizations
as well as sport he had a particular
interest in scientific and technological
research
and in conservation of the environment
to so many he was a considerable asset
who came with clout and commitment
to my generation and i think the
generation
younger too it was an invaluable
weapon to know that when there was a
serious issue for conservation kind
you had somebody who automatically
did their homework and when they spoke
with the voice that they knew carried
worldwide
actually spoke as it were truth
and fact and not anything to do with
self-aggrandizing sort of
self-importance but sticking
absolutely and completely to the
important elements of the subject in
hand
and that was him a life well-lived will
be a story well told
certainly here of the star pupil who's
shown in public life
and in public service james matthews sky
news
gordenstein